[Music]
[Music]
more than 50 of afghanistan's
370 districts have fallen
since the beginning of may most
districts that have been taken
surround provincial capitals suggesting
that the taliban are positioning
themselves
to try and take these capitals once
foreign forces
are fully withdrawn
[Music]
under the watchful eyes of the
international community
our people have witnessed only the worst
violence of the past two decades since
the signing of the boha peace agreement
and especially since the announcement
announcement by the united states and
nato
what their troops would draw the
massacre of school boys in local
schoolgirls in west kabul diviners in
the north
and vaccinators in the east over the
past weeks
are just some examples of the senseless
violence inflicted by taliban and their
slcs
[Music]
it was interesting the security council
listening to the speeches from the
various countries yes they all said the
talks needed to get back on track but
then they switched
to the humanitarian situation and what
to do about that and the feeling i'm
getting
from un headquarters is a lot of the
focus in the coming months is going to
be trying to mitigate
a humanitarian emergency and senior
officials have told me there is the
prospect
of a mass refugee crisis
you